[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur le public Sénat pour un nouveau
numéro de 100% Sénat l'émission qui vous
fait vivre les travaux de la Haute
Assemblée l'Office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques faites ces 40 ans c'est
un organe commun aux deux chambres du
Parlement qui a pour mission d'informer
les parlementaires sur les conséquences
de nos choix scientifiques et
technologiques et à l'occasion de ces 40
ans plusieurs tableaux rondes sont
organisées notamment sur les énergies
renouvelables et l'usage des pesticides
je vous propose de les suivre
alors on va commencer tout de suite par
la première
controverse si vous voulez bien et pour
ouvrir
ce n'est pas courtois mais on va comme
le problème est posé à partir des
énergies renouvelables que Gérard David
Marchal nous présente le point de vue de
l'ADEME dont on peut penser qu'elle est
structurellement proche des énergies
renouvelables puissent nous dire comment
l'agence voit le rôle exclusif principal
subsidiaire des énergies renouvelables
en matière de production
et je vous donne la parole
Messieurs les Présidents
mesdames et messieurs merci beaucoup
d'avoir invité l'ADEME pour cette
cet anniversaire de de l'OPEX auquel on
participe effectivement régulièrement
et merci de me donner la parole alors
l'ADEM l'agence de la transition
écologique a effectivement dans ses
missions le fait de lever les freins au
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
lever les freins au déploiement des
énergies renouvelables ça veut dire
éclairer tous les débats autour de ces
énergies qui comme toutes les activités
humaines ont des impacts présentent des
opportunités alors quand on dit
lever les freins ça veut dire qu'on
assure notre rôle d'agence d'expertise
sur ce sujet comme sur les autres une
agence d'expertise aide financement
l'ADEME qui donc tire son expertise en
partie des projets qu'elle finance on
est un opérateur qui finance la R&D sur
ce sujet comme comme sur d'autres
financement de thèses et suivi de
projets de R&D qui nous permettent
d'être au fait des dernières avancées
qu'elles soient technologiques ou
sociales
on ne perd un certain nombre
d'études qui visent à qualifier ces
énergies que ce soit des études
économiques des études sur les impacts
environnementaux des études sur
l'insertion des énergies renouvelables
dans les mix énergétiques des études de
potentiel
toutes ces études là sont publiques et
puis on est également en contact avec le
terrain puisqu'on est également
financeur du déploiement d'un certain
nombre de ces énergies renouvelables au
titre notamment du fond chaleur qui nous
permet de et du fond de décarbonations
de l'industrie depuis quelques années
qui nous permet de en finançant ces
projets que ce soit de chaleur
renouvelables de des carbonation de
l'industrie lettres au contact du
terrain et de voir aussi les difficultés
et les opportunités qu'elles peuvent
représenter
ceci étant dit donc sur le rôle de
l'ADEME
rappelons juste un instant le contexte
notre la question posée sur notre
approvisionnement énergétique déjà doit
interroger la situation actuelle et ce
que nous consommons aujourd'hui nous
consommons environ 1600 tt d'énergie
finale en France en 2021
et cette énergie elle est on peut on
peut la compatibilité
de différentes façons à la fois par
source cette énergie elle est
aujourd'hui essentiellement fossile 60%
de l'énergie qu'on consomme et fossile
20% nucléaire et 20% renouvelable on
arrive à 100%. cette énergie elle est
aussi
répartie selon différents vecteurs
environ 27% de cette énergie c'est de
l'électricité 23% du gaz et le reste
c'est donc du pétrole en gros et cette
énergie elle est également consommée par
différents secteurs et on peut
approximer que globalement quasiment la
moitié de cette énergie est consommée
par le bâtiment tertiaire ou résidentiel
principalement sous forme de chauffage
et 30% pour les transports donc ça c'est
l'état des lieux actuels cet état des
lieux voilà
notre grande dépendance aux importations
d'énergie aujourd'hui je rappelle 60% de
l'énergie qu'on consomme est importée et
seulement 20% et renouvelable alors
partant de là quel est effectivement la
place des énergies renouvelables dans le
futur on a mené un certain nombre de
travaux sur ces sujets là à la fois des
études de potentiel des études aux
limites puisque la dame il y a quelques
années maintenant avaient regardé la
question de mix électrique ou de mix
gazier 100% renouvelable c'était des
études véritablement pour pousser les
les limites et vérifier ses potentiels
et on a publié plus récemment fin 2021
un travail qui s'appelle transition 2005
ans travail de prospective de quatre
scénarios de neutralité carbone
quatre scénarios donc de société
française neutre en carbone dans
lesquelles on a exploré des voies très
variées pour atteindre cette neutralité
carbone
neutralité carbone qui concerne les
aspects qui vont bien au-delà de la
question énergétique puisque on y
interroge à la fois l'alimentation
l'agriculture
l'évolution des mobilités et bien
entendu les questions de mix énergétique
dans ce contexte là c'est important de
rappeler que on parle dans la question
que vous posez d'énergie et non pas que
dès l'électricité et donc de ce fait les
énergies renouvelables dont on parle
sont assez variés et d'ailleurs dans les
20% d'énergie renouvelable dont je
parlais tout à l'heure pourtant de
savoir qu'aujourd'hui ces énergies
renouvelables sont essentiellement de la
biomasse puis de l'hydroélectricité et
que celles qui ont une très forte
dynamique de développement aujourd'hui
le photovolté qui a éolien ne représente
à ce jour qu'une faible part de
l'énergie renouvelable produite c'est
néanmoins sur elle que l'essentiel de la
croissance à venir
à reposer
à la fois donc des technologies de
production que constitue l'éolien le
photovoltaïque mais également des
technologies pour le chauffage notamment
des pompes à chaleur et de la biomasse
sont les quatre énergies majeures dans
lesquelles dans les différents scénarios
qu'on a pu faire le développement et on
va dire incontournable si on veut
atteindre la neutralité carbone alors
quelle est la part des énergies
renouvelables dans ces mix énergétiques
en 2050 dans ces travaux donc très
variés on a une part d'énergie
renouvelable dans 2050 qui qui varie
entre 70% ou plus et ça quelle que soit
les choix on va dire fait sur le
nucléaire par exemple
et je parle de 70% de
l'approvisionnement énergétique et non
pas que électrique donc effectivement
d'après l'Ademe d'après les travaux
qu'on peut mener les énergies
renouvelables ont une belle voix devant
elle ça veut dire multiplier par 3 au
moins leur production par rapport à
aujourd'hui alors
[Musique]
dans ce propos liminaire je veux juste
insister sur quelques points le fait que
on est devant un bouquet d'énergie
renouvelable une diversification notre
mix énergétique on va pas parler et
remplacer le pétrole et le gaz par une
ou deux énergies renouvelables et bien
par une diversité un bouquet néanmoins
faut pas se voiler la face on ne fera
pas la transition uniquement avec les
énergies renouvelables que tout le monde
aime bien parce qu'on ne les voit pas on
entend parler souvent des énergies
marines ou de la géothermie certes nous
on pousse aussi beaucoup la géothermie
et on soutient la R&D sur les énergies
marines mais mais la transition
écologique ne se fera pas sans les
majors les énergies renouvelables major
que je citais tout à l'heure l'éolien le
photovoltaïque la biomasse les pompes à
chaleur
c'est une certaine diversité qui est
facteur de résilience
ces énergies renouvelables représentent
aussi des opportunités en termes de
souveraineté dans nos travaux en 2050 on
peut réduire de
85%, les importations de produits
pétroliers
c'est donc bien entendu une production
locale qui va se substituer à des
importations donc facteur de
souveraineté important dans la dans la
période actuelle
c'est également un choix qu'on peut
considérer comme économique on a
longtemps eu des énergies renouvelables
qui présentaient des surcoûts par
rapport aux énergies fossiles et
la crise récente a montré le contraire
et les progrès technologiques sur les
énergies renouvelables notamment les
énergies renouvelables électriques les
amènent aujourd'hui dans des champs de
compétitivité avec les autres formes
d'énergie dans les études qu'on a pu
mener à la fois sur le mix électrique ou
sur la chaleur juste deux points sur le
mix électrique aujourd'hui ce sont les
travaux de l'ADEME ou les travaux de RTE
montrent que globalement la question
n'est plus d'opposé les énergies
renouvelables et nucléaires mais que du
point de vue économique en tout cas le
choix n'est pas économique il y a peu de
différence entre des mixes électriques
qui iraient vers du 100% renouvelable et
des mixes qui renouveleraient le
nucléaire
c'est des questions de coûts financement
qui sont derrière il y a bien entendu
des paramètres qui peuvent faire évoluer
un peu ces différences là mais néanmoins
on est assez proche en terme de coûts
sur ces questions là donc c'est pas un
choix économique c'est avant tout un
choix politique un choix industriel sur
la chaleur renouvelable on est là aussi
dans une logique complètement économique
à titre un exemple que je peux donner le
fond chaleur qui est un fond donc opéré
par ADEME pour subventionner la chaleur
renouvelable
à côté à l'état contribuable environ
3,5 milliards d'euros depuis 10 ans
c'est la totalité des subventions qu'on
a distribué 3,5 milliards d'euros
ça a permis de subventionner des
installations de chaleur renouvelables
qui produisent aujourd'hui environ 40
terrawatts de chaleur renouvelables
uniquement sur l'année dernière avec les
prix du gaz de l'an dernier
le fond chaleur a été remboursé en un an
c'est-à-dire que les installations de
production de chaleur renouvelables de
biomasse de géothermie qui ont produit
l'an dernier alors 40 terrains si elles
avaient dû produire cette énergie à
partir de gaz alors écoutez c'est 3,5
milliards d'euros donc voilà enfin il y
a des choix aujourd'hui qui un contexte
qui change complètement la donne sur le
sujet des énergies des énergies
renouvelables alors deux sujets
importants également pour terminer la
question de l'appropriation locale de
ces technologies comme je disais on est
face à un déploiement très ambitieux
multiplié par 3 leur leur production
elles sont nécessairement déployées sur
les territoires les territoires ont des
gisements différents ont des besoins
différents dans des potentiels
différents il y a une véritable question
en ce moment où la question de la
planification écologique et posée
comment répartir ces énergies
renouvelables comment susciter la pro
comment répartir l'effort puisque tout
les territoires sont pas égaux ils ne
sont pas enfin il y a des populations
différentes il y a des
territoires plus agricoles que d'autres
avec plus de biomasse que d'autres avec
plus de soleil que d'autres donc on a
une vraie question aujourd'hui de
pouvoir réconcilier des schémas de
planification on va dire remontant qui
viennent des territoires comme les pcaet
comme les schémas régionaux
comme les schéma régionaux avec ces
objectifs nationaux qui jusqu'à présent
ne sont pas réconciliés dans les dans
les précédentes versions de la PPE et
des stradettes et puis un point pour
terminer ces énergies renouvelables
elles ont certes des potentiels
techniques extrêmement importants
néanmoins dans ces scénarios qu'on peut
faire ou on se base des scénarios
réalistes de déploiement
on a des gisements limités faut pas
l'oublier rien qu'en terme de
déploiement industriel ou en termes de
de
d'acceptation d'appropriation voire de
prélèvements de biomasse où on est sur
des questions de compromis entre
prélèvements puis de carbone ça sera
évoqué tout à l'heure
on estime difficile d'aller beaucoup
au-delà de 1000 terrawers de production
d'énergie renouvelables on a on a des
fourchettes un peu variées autour de ce
chiffre là je le titre à titre de
l'exemple à peu près 1000 terrawatts de
gisements en 2050
ça ça veut dire que notre consommation
doit réduire je vous parlais tout à
l'heure d'une consommation de 1600
amateurs on a effectivement des
objectifs de réduction qui sont fixés
dans la loi mais on ne saura pas faire
un approvisionnement même à 70%
renouvelable sans réduire notre
consommation que ce soit via
l'efficacité énergétique les
technologies ou via l'évolution des
comportements ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la sobriété qui ne sont pas
nécessairement une privation mais qui
peuvent aussi constituer une opportunité
pour retrouver plus de sens
voilà un dernier point j'ai beaucoup
parlé 2030 de 2050 on a également
aujourd'hui des nouveaux objectifs au
niveau européen sur l'horizon 2035 avec
fit for fifty-five 2030
c'est réduction drastique de -55% des
émissions de CO2 change la donne dans la
trajectoire à adopter à court terme
et je pense que Valérie il faut donc
pourra le confirmer on a un enjeu sans
regret avant cet horizon là de
développer coûte que coûte les énergies
renouvelables puisque et la sobriété
puisque avant cet horizon on ne pourra
pas augmenter la production nucléaire
les nouveaux les nouvelles installations
ne seront pas en service avant cet
horizon là donc pour atteindre ses
objectifs à l'horizon 2035 je pense
qu'il y a pas d'opposition à avoir on a
de toute façon besoin des énergies
renouvelables merci beaucoup
et bien David Marshall moi je vous
remercie pour avoir tenu votre
engagement temps ce qui est formidable
et ça permet
d'ouvrir la controverse en donnant la
parole à il faut don et surtout vous
permettre de préparer vos propres
questions
merci beaucoup
accueillir hier soir je crois que vous
faites il est 40 ans de lopex et nous on
fêter les 50 ans dans la semaine on a
été créés en 1973 on est quand une
société savante et la société
donc je recommence je recommence oui
donc je voulais vous dire quoi j'étais
particulièrement ému d'être invité
aujourd'hui puisqu'il reçoit ont fêtait
nos 50 ans on a été créé en 1973 au
moment où a été décidé le programme
français qu'on est société savante des
ingénieurs des scientifiques du
nucléaire et en même temps hier il y
avait les 150 ans de la Société
Française de Physique que notre grande
sœur de société savante scientifiques
donc c'était vraiment
un jour un jour faste pour pour la place
de la science
et alors je voulais vous dire que donc
on a regardé un certain nombre de débats
présidentielles en fait on a regardé à
cette occasion le débat de 80 le débat
de 2007
donc cette question
nucléaire renouvelable a été déjà dans
ces débats là et je dirais que pour moi
la controverse elle est pas elle est pas
sûre et ce qu'il faut du renouvelable la
controverse c'est vraiment la
controverse sur les 100% renouvelables
en fait vraiment c'est là qu'elle a
controverse elle n'existait pas en 80
François Mitterrand a dit qu'il voulait
il voulait pas le tout nucléaire mais il
voulait un mix diversifié avec du
nucléaire et pareil dans le débat entre
ses colonnes royales et Nicolas Sarkozy
en 2016 c'est vraiment une controverse
pour moi qui apparaît dans le débat
public français avec le débat de 2012 en
fait c'est vraiment à ce moment là alors
c'est alors c'est pour moi c'est
vraiment politique
pourquoi c'est parce qu'en fait bon déjà
on le sait depuis longtemps le nucléaire
est porte des halos symboliques d'hiver
il porte le halo symbolique de la bombe
il porte le à l'eau symbolique de de
l'état de la place de l'État
il porte le symbolique de la science
alors bizarrement de la croissance alors
qu'il y a des gens qui sont pour le
nucléaire et pour la décroissance
plus récemment plus récemment le
patriarcat moi j'ai été invité dans des
Colocs ecoféministes voilà donc on a des
débats sur Twitter sur ces sujets voilà
donc il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
opposés pour nucléaire mais
principalement je crois au-delà avec le
symbolique qu'il porte voilà alors cette
controverse elle est compliquée parce
qu'elle est
elle utilise des des outils
scientifiques qui sont les modèles
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait chaque chaque
porteur d'un projet à son modèle qui
valide techniquement ce qu'il dit il y a
pas que la France vous savez bien sûr le
rôle du scénario Negawatt
l'utilisation politique du scénario aux
États-Unis Bernie Sanders il porte aussi
un scénario anti-nucléaire 100%
renouvelable par qui fait par un prof de
Stanford donc c'est un peu compliqué
pour les citoyens parce qu'en fait à
chaque fois il y a une position qui est
prise et puis dernier on dit mais moi
j'ai mon modèle scientifique paru dans
telle revue à comité de lecture qui dit
que finalement ma position elle est
vraie elle est tenable elle a une alors
c'est extrêmement compliqué pour les
citoyens parce qu'il faut quand même
rentrer dans le détail de ces modèles
pour comprendre la différence
méthodologique et puis vous savez
comment un modèle ben il dépend de
laquelle de l'information qui est
rentrée dedans et l'information qui est
entraînement sincèrement on la connaît
pas un modèle à 2050
quel est quel sera les comportements des
Français en termes de consommation quel
sera le prix des technologies quel est
le prix du salaire en 2050 voilà
la disponibilité des technologies
qu'est-ce qui se passera dans le monde
d'un point de vue géolé politique tout
ça on ne le sait pas et on peut avoir
des experts très très forts faut quand
même faire preuve d'humilité puisque je
vous rappelle qu'on n'avait pas prédit
le choc pétrolier de 73 on n'avait pas
prévu l'arrivée du gaz de schiste aux
États-Unis dans les années 2000 2010 et
on a juste pas prédit la crise en
Ukraine avec la crise du gaz européen
donc il faut quand même être extrêmement
humble en matière de modélisation
ce qu'il faut c'est utiliser des
trajectoires les comprendre les partager
et se dire qu'elle est finalement la
trajectoire la plus robuste que je que
je peux suivre sachant que il y a rien
de plus instable que l'énergie il y a
plein de choses que je ne sais pas donc
qu'est-ce qui est finalement robuste
pour moi est résilient à la mode voilà
je crois que c'est moins important alors
il y a eu des travaux comme l'a dit
David à la dame il y a eu des travaux
chez nagawatt
il y a aussi des travaux côté
pronucléaires il y a des travaux avec
beaucoup de nucléaires j'insiste que je
pense pas enfin David va peut-être me
contredire qu'il y ait des travaux 100%
nucléaires je crois qu'on dit jamais vu
peut-être vu un mais bon
de notoriété et donc de toute façon les
scénarios même portés par jean-luclair
il y a des renouvelables et d'ailleurs
je rappelle que le club nucléaire créé
par Madame la Ministre reine espany
renard chez il est aussi pro
renouvelable c'est le club renouvelable
qui est anti-nucléaire au niveau europ
éen
alors ce que je voulais vous dire
je vais insister sur les scénarios RTE
pourquoi c'est parce qu'en fait ils ont
été partagés c'est à dire que c'est des
scénarios ou à peu près tous les acteurs
français il y a concertation a duré deux
ans tout le monde connaît bien la
méthodologie puisque tout le monde a
bossé dessus en fait voilà on a donné
nos inputs donc on sait comment il est
fait et là où je trouve qu'ils ont créé
une
je veux pas laisser penser que je
critique le travail qui a été fait par
David évidemment puisque je parlais de
travaux Arthur auquel il a participé
aussi
c'est qu'il est intéressant parce que
justement vous savez que des premiers
sujets sur lesquels j'en sont pas
d'accord c'est le niveau de consommation
donc il y a trois niveaux de
consommation
donc la ville l'a dit bon il y a un
niveau moyen de référence qui était à
l'époque scénario SNBC et puis il y a un
niveau sobre de sobriété donc un niveau
de consommation plus faible et puis il y
a un scénario avec un scénario de
consommation plus haute qui
correspondait à réindustrialisation
profonde une augmentation de la part de
l'industrie dans le dans le PIB 2050 qui
a des effets vertus à la fois pour la
croissance économique française pour
l'emploi mais aussi rappelons-le pour
des carbonation puisque tout ce qui est
produit en France s'est produit avec une
électricité bas carbone donc on y met
moins
que quand on importe des produits donc
il y a trois niveaux là je fais une
petite parenthèse puisque ce scénario
est en pleine pas révision à 2050 en
tout cas il y a un nouveau scénario en
cours de RTE on est actuellement dans
une une perspective aussi de la
consommation d'électricité très forte
qui est à la fois
qui a un scénario de réindustrialisation
profonde et de sobriété en même temps
voilà donc c'est et malgré ça on est
quand même des niveaux de 600 tiers à
wattheure en 2035 ce qui a joué pas mal
ça a été que les input à la fois de
en termes de demande d'hydrogène de
l'industrie parce que faire de
l'hydrogène ça demande beaucoup
d'électricité
et puis
et puis aussi les fuel arrivent dans
l'aviation en particulier donc ça aussi
ça demande beaucoup d'électricité donc
actuellement on est vraiment dans une
situation et ça je crois que ça a été
aussi un des points importants d'avis on
a parlé pas mal il y a eu dans le débat
public on a pas mal étudié une confusion
complète entre énergie électricité
pendant très longtemps
quand vous regardez par exemple des bas
des NT1 de 2012 on mélange les deux
allègrement
et donc alors qu'en fait et c'est pas
forcément facile à comprendre pour pour
des non initiés il faut à la fois
baisser notre consommation d'énergie
mais pour baisser la consommation
d'énergie il faut augmenter la
consommation d'électricité
je vais le débat le débat présidentiel
du deuxième tour 2017 il mélangeait
agrément les deux se tromper sur les
chiffres etc donc il faut vraiment
insister là-dessus je pense aux citoyens
c'est vraiment faire la différence entre
les deux
donc on va avoir besoin de beaucoup
d'électricité ça je crois que c'est
relativement consensuel alors ce que
disait David l'a évoqué l'étude 2050 RTA
donc je vous disais trois niveaux de
consommation c'était pour mettre un peu
tout le monde d'accord enfin chacun est
ce qu'il voulait et puis il y avait six
trajectoires trajectoires sans
renouvellement du parc nucléaire et
trois trajectoires avec renouvellement
du parc nucléaire à différents niveaux
de renouvellement
il faut savoir qu'à l'époque puisque ça
date de fin 21 on fermait les réacteurs
puisqu'on avait en suivi la PPE donc
enfermé 12 réacteurs et l'hypothèse
aussi c'est qu'on n'allait pas autre
façon sur les réacteurs actuels donc on
a une sorte de d'effet falaise terrible
à partir de 2040 puisqu'on les a
construit extrêmement vite donc ils
arrivent tous à 60 ans en même temps la
boum
et alors ce que nous disait ce que nous
dit cette étude elle nous dit plein de
choses
alors bon il y a une différence de coût
c'est vrai que David a dit que la
différence de coût était principalement
liée à la façon dont est financée le
nucléaire en particulier parce que
l'étude mettez un financement à 4% sur
sur l'ensemble des technologies
avec une analyse de sensibilité à 7% ce
qui est vraiment très intéressant c'est
que la grosse différence c'est pas le
coût de production des technologies
c'est un peu terminé c'est à dire quand
vous regardez coût production nucléaire
renouvelable c'est à peu près la même
chose ce qui fait la différence c'est
les coûts de réseau
inéditrtea et puis les coups de
flexibilité du réseau
dans des groupes de travail actuellement
pour la préparation de la loi elbeke
enedis ils ont quand même annoncé 90
milliards d'investissements d'ici à 2040
sur juste le réseau de distribution
d'électricité donc c'est vraiment ces
couleurs qui font la différence ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui en science
économique l'écosystèmes aujourd'hui en
sciences économique on dit plus il y
avait le LCO vous avez le live cost of
electricity qui était le coût de
production des outils maintenant regarde
de plus en plus et ce que fait l'étude
RTE le coup système qui inclut la
distribution
le transport d'électricité et puis les
coûts d'équilibrage du réseau dans le
cadre de RTE ce sont des il y a
évidemment de la flexibilité de la
demande et il y a aussi des turbines à
hydrogène ma carbone pour équilibrer le
réseau
donc ça c'est très important et puis je
vais pas prendre autant j'avais fini par
exemple ce qui est vraiment aussi
intéressant je trouve dans le scénario
ce qui se pose la question de la
robustesse et ça je pense que c'est
vraiment important
contenu du passé qu'on a pu avoir sur la
sur les chocs énergétiques et donc
chacun ses forces et ses faiblesses je
dirais
donc je vais commencer par les
faiblesses du nucléaire
la faiblesse nucléaire c'est est-ce
qu'on va réussir à construire tous ces
EPS
donc il y a eu un grand débat donc vous
le savez le choix qui a été fait c'est
le N2 c'est le 14 réacteurs avant 2000
50 donc chez les différents associations
nucléaires il y a eu un grand débat
là-dessus mais pourquoi on peut faire
que 14 on peut en faire 20 on peut faire
25 c'est bon ce qu'on a dit nous on est
tout à fait d'accord avec
sur le choix qui a été fait c'est qu'en
fait l'important pour nous c'est surtout
de commencer à les construire et
d'arriver à faire un rythme de croisière
après on verra combien on est capable
d'en faire mais la question c'est ce
qu'on est capable de se remettre en
capillibilité de construire d'avoir un
vrai programme industriel pour commencer
à construire donc ça c'était le premier
sujet il y a un deuxième sujet
qui a pas vraiment été controversé à
l'époque mais qui est un sujet
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on peut aller de
la 60 ans je vous dis il y a un effet
falaise on va pas tout fermer en même
temps donc est-ce qu'on peut avoir des
réacteurs qui vont de la 60 ans ça se
fait aux États-Unis mais on n'a pas la
même autorité de sûreté donc je pense
que d'ailleurs sur ces sujets lopex va
être beaucoup saisi
de savoir est-ce qu'on peut prolonger de
la 60 ans enfin pour l'instant prolonger
pour être 50 ans mais c'est extrêmement
important pour la politique énergétique
de française de savoir le plus tôt
possible si on peut aller au delà de 60
ans parce que si on peut pas aller au de
60 ans on n'est pas très bien quoi voilà
ça c'est les faiblesses côté nucléaire
il y a la question du financement dans
ta parlé David qui a été mis dans les
rapports c'est 4 %. donc ce qui a été
choisi dans la méthodologie c'est qu'en
fait on pouvait pas savoir comment
serait financer le nouveau programme
donc on a mis tout le monde à 4% faut
savoir qu'il y a des programmes qui sont
financés à 4% dans le monde en Hongrie
ils sont à 3 %
tout dépend du schéma financier qui est
mis en place et surtout dans
l'implication des deux des deux seuls
qui peuvent vraiment porter le risque de
tel projet parce que faire porter le
risque de ces projets sur le
constructeur on l'a vu à on a vu la
faillite d'arriver en France pour la
Finlande et aussi de difficultés de
westinien sur le premier chantier
américain donc donc il y en a que deux
grands acteurs qui peuvent porter le
risque c'est passer le contribuable ou
le consommateur voilà
donc s'il y a cette question du
financement qui n'est pas tranchée
aujourd'hui et puis et puis voilà alors
ça c'est la partie force et faiblesse du
nucléaire ça fait faiblesse risque sur
le nucléaire la risque côté renouvelable
quoi identité
identifié par l'OPEX alors c'est d'abord
le risque notre capacité à déployer aux
vitesses requises parce qu'on est
vitesse très élevée qui vont parfois
au-delà de ce qu'on fait nos meilleures
voisins que ce soit sur l'éolien
offshore ou solaire on est capable de
faire à la même vitesse que à la fin en
termes de gestion de projet de capacités
industrielle et puis en termes de ce que
le public va comment le public va avoir
le diplôme de ces projets et puis aussi
les disponibilité à l'échelle
industrielle des technologies de
flexibilité
en particulier les questions de stockage
voilà un petit peu donc le bout du
compte en fait moi ça sera ma position
nous on est vraiment évidemment
convaincu de la valeur du nucléaire dans
le système électrique pas seulement
français mais européen puisqu'il est pas
carbone et pilotable donc il stabilise
l'ensemble du réseau d'autant plus et ça
RTL disait récemment tous nos voisins
vont faire énormément de renouvelables
donc on sera le rôle du nucléaire sur la
plaque électrique européenne il est
extrêmement important pour stabiliser le
réseau
on est convaincu évidemment de la place
que le nucléaire a dans la stratégie
industrialisation française puisque
c'est notre troisième secteur
et
voilà mais je pense que j'espère que la
controverse est en cours d'extinction et
on arrive vers un consensus parce que
évidemment on a besoin d'une claire et
du renouvelable voilà merci oui sur les
la comparaison des coûts effectivement
c'est plus les coups de production mais
les coût système complet qui faut
comparer donc mettre en avant les les
seuls coûts de production
quand même assez discutable entre les
scénarios RTE donc au maximum de 50% de
nucléaire puisque RTE n'a pas voulu
monter au-dessus dans la première dans
la première mouture et les scénarios le
plus
le plus renouvelable c'était en gros 20
milliards d'euros par an il y a une
étude très importante de l'OCDE Nea qui
est basé sur le même principe la
comparaison des coûts des systèmes
complets mais cette fois avec peut-être
des scénarios un peu plus réalistes qui
vont de 90% de nucléaire 10% de
renouvelables à 70% renouvelables 30%
nucléaires qui est bizarrement abouti à
peu près à cet ordre de grandeur aussi
c'est-à-dire 20 milliards d'euros par an
de de coûts entre les entre les deux
systèmes voilà et puis vous avez parlé
vous avez eu un raisonnement en parlant
du coup du gaz l'année dernière sur les
infrastructures et les programmes
d'investissement de gaz si on fait le
même raisonnement pour le nucléaire en
partant des coûts de l'électricité
l'année dernière
le père de Flamanville qui est ce qu'il
est et rentabilisé en trois ans avec ce
même raisonnement à ces mêmes données
voilà par rapport aux différentes
questions évoquées alors j'ai
finalement assez peu parlé l'électricité
mais les questions que vous posez porter
essentiellement sur le sujet de
l'électricité alors sur le sujet du mix
électrique on réalise des études
effectivement
à l'horizon 2050 depuis depuis 2017 une
période à laquelle je n'étais pas encore
sur cette horizon là donc RTE maintenant
il y est ce qui est très bien et fait
des travaux extrêmement sérieux sur le
sujet
les travaux de l'ADEME utilisent les
mêmes types d'outils donc on parle bien
les chiffres que je vous donnais sur
lesquivalence des coûts voilà c'est on
modélise aussi le mix électrique dans
son ensemble on prend en compte les
coûts complets du mix avec les questions
de coût de réseau et de coûts
flexibilité
je pense c'est important de pas
interpréter ce que j'ai pu dire par
exemple sur le remboursement de la du
fond chaleur
en un an comme une opposition au sujet
du nucléaire enfin je crois que c'est
vraiment
faut pas faut juste pas oublier que 50%
47% aujourd'hui de l'énergie qu'on
consomme c'est de la elle est consommée
sous forme de chaleur
et que l'électricité nous aussi dans nos
scénarios l'électricité prend une part
beaucoup plus importante dans le mix
électrique dans le mix énergétique alors
ils ont 2050 mais il reste 45% de
l'énergie qui sera pas d'électricité et
qu'il faudra produire aussi en réduisant
nos dépendances donc c'est important
aussi qu'on qu'on développe cette
chaleur renouvelable
sur la question de l'interdépendance
entre les régions c'est effectivement un
changement majeur qui va survenir
aujourd'hui quand on fait des études au
niveau régional on se rend compte que on
importe énormément enfin finalement tout
nos territoires dépendent énormément
aussi des importations d'énergie qui
viennent à la fois en dehors de la
France ou d'ailleurs en France et
l'augmentation de la production locale
d'énergie renouvelable ne signifie pas
autarcie des régions ou autarcie des
territoires c'est important de l'avoir
en tête même dans des travaux qui
peuvent être faits sur les régions
énergie positives des territoires
énergies positives
on va dans un monde où il y aura plus
d'interdépendance plus de solidarité
nécessaire entre territoires puisque
même si on produit tous plus localement
davantage qu'aujourd'hui on va être sur
des profils de production qui vont
nécessiter effectivement une entraide
une solidarité c'est important de le
rappeler
l'importance de cette péréquation et de
du partage de l'effort dont je parlais
tout à l'heure alors on peut
effectivement mener des études plus
locales sur les territoires aujourd'hui
on est en train de voir comment décliner
régionalement les mix énergétiques qui
sont étudiées au niveau national dans le
transition 2050 c'est pas évident ce que
je disais ça dépend beaucoup des
potentiels de chaque territoire
et on va arriver à des valeurs guides
qui peuvent qui vont servir aux régions
pour se doter de trajectoire mais dans
certaines régions il faut avoir
conscience qu'on va être au-delà de
l'énergie positive puisque dans d'autres
régions je pense à l'Île-de-France
notamment on pourra pas bien entendu
produire autant d'énergie qu'on en
consomme donc il y a il y aura
nécessairement des des enjeux de
transferts importants on mène de tels
travaux aussi sur les zones non
interconnectées sur les outre-mer ou là
l'objectif est encore plus ambitieux
avec l'autonomie énergétique de ces
territoires la question de plaque
territoriale
aujourd'hui on étudie ces questions de
grandes zones industrielles au travers
des des ibacs zone industrielle bas
carbone qui sont des travaux de
prospective qui sont des soutiens qui
sont apportés via France 2030 pour aider
ces grosses zones industrielles à faire
de la prospective évaluer leurs besoins
en termes d'infrastructures de CO2
d'hydrogène etc
je pense pas qu'à ce stade elles sont
ouvertes très largement au delà des
frontières par rapport à votre question
sur les plaques et puis sur les
ressources minérales effectivement c'est
un sujet qu'on regarde aussi beaucoup
les quatre scénarios ont donné lieu à
une évaluation des besoins en matériaux
et ce qui est important de d'avoir en
tête c'est que certes les productions
d'énergie vont nécessiter davantage de
matériaux mais c'est surtout l'évolution
de nos consommations de ce qu'on
constate c'est les points les plus
criants en termes de besoins notamment
sur le lithium sur le cuivre sont tirés
par le développement du véhicule
électrique qui est nécessaire dans tous
les scénarios mais qui représente des
volumes plus importants que les énergies
renouvelables notamment
et sur la question de la souveraineté
alors effectivement on a dans nos
scénarios une volonté de de relocaliser
un certain nombre de productions
industrielle moins sans doute que n'a pu
le faire RTE dans son scénario rien
industrialisation profonde
je pense que c'est aussi important de
voir d'un point de vue opérationnel ce
qui est fait aujourd'hui il y a des
soutiens publics très importants qui
sont octroyés sur les questions de
production de réindustrialisation on est
opérateur France 2030 et donc on finance
à ce titre à la fois des
infrastructures de production
notamment futurs
usines on voit qu'il y a aujourd'hui des
projets d'usine de batterie de
production de photovoltaïques
de production aussi sur l'éolien
offshore donc c'est de souveraineté elle
se construit elle se construit aussi
avec de la visibilité puisque comme dans
le cas du nucléaire a besoin de
visibilité pour que les investissements
puissent être faits mais nul doute que
au niveau français et européen le marché
des énergies renouvelables est-elle à
l'horizon 2050 que des investissements
sont possibles et rentables
alors sur la question
de la des matières il y a un certain
nombre de travaux qui qui sont publiés
je pense un scénario mondial de l'Agence
internationale d'énergie sur la
transition énergétique qui s'appuie
justement sur leur nz2
donc il y a un vrai enjeu sur le système
électrique il y a un mode commun qui est
le cuivre la consommation de cuivre
mais c'est assez impressionnant ça
double au moins voir plus enfin il y a
des ratios extrêmement importants et ça
on en a tous besoin évidemment
le nucléaire est assez sobre alors il y
a deux il y a deux dimensions il y a la
dimension de la construction alors on
est sobre parce que quand on construit
on construit pour 60 ans 80 ans alors
évidemment
rapporté au kilowattheure et comme en
plus on est pilotable et qu'on produit
beaucoup on est très sobre en matière il
y a un peu d'acier évidemment ils sont
en train nucléaire il y a aussi un peu
nion nickel et un peu de chrome pour les
alliages de la chaudière
mais on est assez moins la question se
pose sur l'uranium et c'est vrai que
actuellement on est dans des scénarios
de relance forte avec un potentiellement
un doublement du de la production
nucléaire et de la capacité nucléaire
pour 2050 donc là on attend septembre un
nouveau rapport de la World nucléaire
associé pour faire une évolution des
ressources minières en uranium sachant
que comme vous le savez qu'on a des
ressources des puisque l'OPEX a publié
un rapport dessus on peut faire de la
gêne 4 et auquel cas on a sur notre sol
tout ce qu'il nous faut pour très
longtemps voilà si on est capable de
valoriser en particulier notre uranium
appauvri voilà
alors donc ça c'était sur la partie sur
la partie ressources sur la partie
souveraineté donc en effet on a la
chance d'avoir une industrie nationale
on n'est pas à 100% il y a un certain
nombre de pièces il y a un certain
nombre d'opérations actuellement de
relocalisation qui sont pas forcément
visibles mais actuellement par exemple
Framatome sur leurs usines de
Saint-Marcel et de et du Creusot sont en
train de relocaliser un certain nombre
de fabrication qui était faite
en République tchèque au Japon par
exemple donc il y a un travail
actuellement qui est fait sur ce sujet
alors on a une chaîne française il faut
penser à la chaîne européenne pourquoi
c'est parce qu'on a donc cet objectif de
150 gigawatts de nucléaire en 2050 qui
voudrait dire qu'on construirait 120
gigawatts en Europe donc 15 pays qui ont
plus le 16e yokai qui en dit qui
souhaitait compter sur le nucléaire dans
le futur on a des projets je disais ce
matin que les que les que les le
Pays-Bas sont en train de considérer
trois pays dont la France pour la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires et donc la seule chaîne
industrielle
clair en France c'est celle de la France
voilà donc il faudra que cette chaîne
devienne européenne
si on veut pouvoir accompagner
l'ensemble des pays européens dans ces
programmes de construction neuve et je
vous dis ça parce que les Américains
sont là ils sont arrivés en Pologne en
Roumanie avec avec beaucoup de
financement
et je pense qu'il faut vraiment qu'on
réfléchisse à notre souveraineté sur ces
sur ces projets de construction neuve
européenne et la France peut être
vraiment un allié de l'ensemble des pays
européens sur ce sujet puisque j'ai la
main j'en profite quand même parce que
je n'ai pas dit dans mon introduction et
je voulais faire de remercier lopex
évidemment pour le travail
d'accompagnement de programme nucléaire
qui a été fait depuis sa création dans
le débat qui a eu sur les opère à panli
un moment donné il y a eu un débat sur
le fait que nucléaire n'était pas
démocratique
et même eu des expressions un peu
extrêmes genre la démocratie française
est malade du nucléaire ça a été dit et
regardant justement l'occasion de nous
50 ans l'histoire et on en a parlé à
l'occasion du ici de la de l'événement
organisé par la Fondation Giscard
d'Estaing
le nucléaire en fait les décisions sur
nucléaires ont été prises avec la
pratique démocratique française de
l'époque dans les années 70 et ensuite
évidemment la création de l'OPEX le
nucléaire a été un des sujets de travail
de lopex tout à fait naturellement et
puis aussi l'arrivée de la démocratie
française la démocratie participative
plus tard même et donc voilà je voulais
vraiment remercier le texte d'avoir
accompagné justement
le développement du nucléaire dans avec
la pratique démocratique que le peix a
permis de mettre en place merci merci
beaucoup on passe à la deuxième
controverse sur réduire l'usage des
produits phytosanitaires agricoles
est-ce mettent en danger et la
production alimentaire c'est un sujet
majeur je crois qu'il a été peu abordé
par haddocks allemand par par l'Office
dans le dans le passé sauf avec
Catherine procacia elle président
l'archet en a dit on a on a tous les
deux fait un rapport sur la chlordécone
il y a eu d'autres rapports
qui ont peut-être
dont on a peut-être moins parlé mais
c'est un sujet qui aujourd'hui est au
cœur de l'actualité et parce que
pourquoi on va pas plus vite il y a un
échec dans les objectifs qu'on avait de
réduction des pesticides on arrivera pas
à 50% de réduction en 2030
vraisemblablement on est encore à 43000
tonnes aujourd'hui
pourquoi pas les plus vite vers une
agriculture sans pesticides mais il y a
plein de questions qui se posent à
travers une question générique c'est de
quelle pesticides on parle
et je crois que là c'est pas clair y
compris y compris sur les chiffres parce
que quand stagne ça baisse légèrement
quand même au niveau national c'est très
variable suivant les pays européens mais
quand les les pesticides de synthèse
baissent légèrement augmentent très
fortement les produits biocontrôle
et
se pose donc une première question
qu'est-ce quelles sont les les
pesticides autorisés aujourd'hui est-ce
que les pesticides qui restent les
traits dangereux est-ce que c'est des
pesticides à faible risque qu'est-ce
qu'on peut parler de pesticides à faible
risque qu'est-ce qu'on autorise pour
l'agriculture biologique est-ce que par
exemple des substances chimiques comme
le fer que comme le cuivre ou le soufre
c'est c'est pas nocif y compris pour les
sols ces questions sont peut-être pas
suffisamment abordés ensuite
est-ce que ça peut entraîner une baisse
de la production alimentaire c'est la
question c'est la question principale je
crois que c'est une question majeure
majeure non pas pour les pays du Nord
parce que quand on voit les arguments
qui sont développés on peut très bien le
faire parce que 60% c'est pour
l'alimentation du bétail parce que il y
a une grosse partie qui est pour la
grosse chimie est-ce que c'est valable
dans tous les pays du monde
et enfin je crois qu'il y a une question
que je que je poserai à Christian wig
d'abord puisque il a participé
à en tant que directeur scientifique de
l'inrae et comme ingénieur à Grenoble
docteur en génétique et en amélioration
des plantes de formation Christian Louis
qui a supervisé de nombreux programmes
scientifiques on a travaillé ensemble
d'ailleurs sur dans une audition
publique décentralisée déjà à Gruissan
sur la transition des systèmes de
production agricole il est actuellement
animateur du programme de recherche
cultivé et protéger autrement dans le
cadre du travail de prospective sur
l'agriculture européenne sans pesticides
en 2050 et
l'Inra linrah a bien fait de travailler
de manière systémique et non plus par
silo indépendant sur ces questions mais
est-ce que pour arriver à ces solutions
les pour arriver à ces solutions et
est-ce que c'est du seul du monde
agricole
est-ce que le changement dont vous
parlez est-ce que il faut pas associer
la totalité des des la totalité de ceux
qui sont concernés enfin
les pesticides nuisent à la biodiversité
et on a parlé d'extinction
d'insectes on a parlé des seuls pollués
on peut arriver
si certains à des baisses très fortes de
pesticides sans perte de rendement quel
est l'impact et on vous demandera
Madame Valérie Chancy chancigo de
traiter de cette question Quel est qui
vous êtes chercheur associé en histoire
des sciences et de l'environnement dans
le laboratoire sphère sciences
philosophie histoire de parité ou vos
travaux portent sur l'étude des
relations entre les êtres humains et la
nature et on vous demandera de traiter
de cette question de l'impact sur
l'environnement et de l'impact sur
l'homme et enfin dernière question à
l'échelle de la planète
je parlais de la planète tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'on va pouvoir nourrir 10
milliards de personnes aujourd'hui
sans produit de synthèse et est-ce qu'il
faut combiner des bouquets de solutions
avec
l'agroécologie avec des solutions de
biocontrôle avec du numérique avec de la
génétique un peu comme les
les gens qui sont contre le nucléaire
sont maintenant contre les éoliennes
dans les mêmes où c'est ce que disait
Gérard Longuet tout à l'heure on voit
aujourd'hui
des gens qui à la fois sont contre les
pesticides mais qui sont aussi contre
les solutions de génétiques est-ce que
il faut combiner ces solutions pour
arriver à traiter de cette question
c'est une question majeure voilà je vous
laisse la parole dans l'ordre Christian
8 puis Valérie chancigo et en abordera
le débat avec la salle merci monsieur le
Président merci Messieurs les Présidents
et mesdames
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrice merci de l'invitation le sujet
il est effectivement
un sujet de controverse ici c'est un
sujet de controverse sociétale qu'on a
tous les jours et j'ai beaucoup aimé la
façon dont le titre est rédigé réduire
l'usage des phytos = réduire la
production alimentaire point
d'interrogation en fait ça traduit une
question qu'on trouve souvent mais ça
traduit en fait un billet majeur de la
question à savoir que quand on fait ça
ça revient à dire qu'il y a une équation
ou y = fonction de x à savoir que les
pesticides sont regardées comme un
intrant pour lequel il y a une courbe de
réponse et à partir du moment où vous
avez une corde de réponse ça veut dire
que jusqu'à un certain niveau plus vous
en met plus vous en mettez mieux ça vaut
jusqu'à un optimum et que l'optimum fait
peut être légèrement modulé par le prix
de l'intrant c'est typiquement ce qu'on
fait avec des engrais et la question
c'est de savoir si les pestites sont un
intrant la réponse elle est non
parce qu'en fait la question elle est de
savoir s'il y a une pression de
biogresseur et donc la vraie question
elle est pas faut-il réduire l'usage des
phytos c'est faut-il et là la réponse
serait oui maintenir la protection des
cultures et donc la protection des
cultures qu'il faut assurer c'est pas la
quantité de phytos
et cette protection des cultures allait
elle a comme objectif de maintenir les
burgresseurs en dessous d'un usage d'un
niveau de nuisibilité
plutôt que de chercher à complètement
éradiquer alors vous avez mentionné
quelques éléments de volume
effectivement cette question elle est
souvent mise en avant est-ce que il y a
un échec du plan Écophyto fait l'action
c'est savoir système le système bouge
effectivement depuis que le plan écofito
a été mis en place en 2009 pendant à peu
près 10 ans il y a pas eu de réduction
de volume
et des pesticides chimiques des
pesticides de synthèse il y a pas une
réduction de volume et puis il y a un
fléchissement sur les dernières années
et qui s'accompagnent et là avec une
trajectoire relativement régulière de
l'augmentation des produits
et donc on cherche la solution miracle
qui remplace la solution des pesticides
et en fait ne rien changer dans le
système de production signifie qu'on a
très peu de degrés de liberté et donc on
inversant un peu la question c'est où
peut-on trouver des degrés de liberté et
elle vient pas de réduire la production
alimentaire et bien de savoir quelle est
la production qu'on fera demain et donc
quel sera la demande alimentaire de
demain donc il y a un premier effet de
fixation qui est traduit par le mot
alternative et puis le deuxième effet de
fixation qui est très fort c'est
l'hypothèse qui est que l'on aura
toujours des pesticides disponibles et
cette question c'est ce point-là il est
totalement présent dans ce qui cadre
aujourd'hui les autorisations de mise en
marché ou l'homologation de molécule à
l'échelle européenne c'est le règlement
11 07 2009
qui est basé comme si il y aurait
toujours une ressource disponible et en
fait cette hypothèse là elle est
aujourd'hui totalement battue en brèche
alors le monde agricole dit bah oui mais
de fait il y a moins de pesticides parce
qu'elles sont retirées pour des raisons
d'impact et aujourd'hui en ce moment le
gouvernement malin travaille mystère de
l'agriculture mystère de la recherche de
l'environnement et de la santé mènera
sur en particulier les 75 substances
actives qui sont potentiellement on va
pas dire menacés mais les plus impactés
par le moment de réévaluation dans
lequel ils vont se substances vont se
situer au cours des cinq à sept
prochaines années ça c'est une des
questions effectivement c'est les
impacts sur la santé les impacts sur
l'environnement et puis il y a une un
critère nouveau qui a été introduit en
2017 qui est les risques de génotoxicité
liés aux molécules
mais c'est qu'un tout petit bout de
l'histoire en fait le deuxième pan de
l'histoire c'est qu'on a des pertes
d'efficacité sur les molécules c'est à
dire les molécules elles tapent sur des
organismes vivants qui n'ont qu'une
seule envie c'est de rester en vie et
donc de s'adapter et donc on a des
phénomènes évolutifs par apparition de
résistance et c'est extrêmement visible
dans les herbicides de vous avez
aujourd'hui des
champs de blé vous avez très souvent
beaucoup beaucoup de raies gras ou
beaucoup de vulpins ou beaucoup de fois
la voile c'est uniquement liées au fait
que vous avez des populations qui sont
devenues résistantes à quelques classes
d'herbicides très utilisées en
particulier sulfonyurés et puis vous
avez des résistances parmi les insectes
et c'est une des causes de de la perte
totale des faits des pyrénoïdes parce
que les pucerons ou les altises sont
devenus résistantes à ça donc il y a des
pères d'efficacité et puis l'élément qui
est le plus problématique c'est que le
pipeline et les vides si vous regardez
le nombre de molécules ou le nombre
d'options qui sont proposés à
des autorisations sur l'échelle
européenne sur des autorisations de mise
en marché en France mais il y a de moins
en moins de demandes parce qu'il y a de
moins en moins de de levier d'action et
donc de cible qui sont trouvées par les
les substances chimiques donc de fait le
système doit être amené à bouger alors
je vais pas parler de du deuxième terme
mais on pourra en reparler à la fin le
deuxième terme de l'équation réduire la
production alimentaire ou l'affaire
évoluer on pourra en reparler tout à
l'heure mais si on reste sur la question
des pesticides la question elle est
est-ce qu'on peut assurer la protection
des cultures avec moins de pesticides et
donc assurer l'efficacité
fonctionnelle de découvert végétaux il y
a de fait comme vous l'avez introduit
monsieur le déo dans votre propos
liminaire
différents leviers qu'il faut qu'il faut
combiner et qui sont disponibles le
premier levier qui est potentiellement
celui qui est le plus puissant et qui
pourtant est celui le plus difficile à
mettre en oeuvre c'est de travailler sur
tout ce qui contribue à réduire la
pression si vous avez moins de
biogresseur vous avez moins besoin de
produits de protection des cultures et
deux grandes voies le fait que l'on peut
mobiliser c'est comment on mobilise les
régulations
naturelles il y a eu un travail
d'expertise scientifique collective qui
a été publiée par inray au mois
d'octobre l'année dernière qui montre
quand vous augmentez les la diversité
fonctionnelle à l'échelle d'une parcelle
d'une série de parcelles ou d'un
territoire vous avez un effet
de réduction forte de l'abondance des
bio-agresseurs et donc de fait si vous
avez une réduction de l'abondance et du
agresseurs il arrive que vous passiez en
dessous de du niveau de risque pour la
culture
puis un autre levier c'est ce qu'on peut
dans la même logique augmenter la
complexité des paysages agricoles
basé sur les logiques de de
l'agroécologie et donc il consiste en
fait à augmenter la diversité
fonctionnelle pour augmenter le service
vous pouvez augmenter les services pour
réguler davantage les populations vous
pouvez aussi augmenter les services pour
augmenter la production et donc il y a
des tout plein d'éléments qui montrent
que l'agroécologie et l'évolution des
systèmes de production permet de faire
augmenter le Land équivalent Raichu donc
vous produisez plus par unité de surface
et par an que le standard qui est les
cultures annuelles telles qu'on les
connaît aujourd'hui j'avais oublié que
les cultures annuelles ce qu'on appelle
culture annuelles elles occupent le sol
de 6 à 10 mois par an donc il y a
beaucoup de temps disponibles au milieu
de tout ça donc il y a des possibilités
autour de ça c'est extrêmement efficace
très peu cher et bizarrement très peu
utilisé
parce que la transition impose une
transition et donc ça se confronte à
l'idée que le système ne bougera pas
deuxième levier monsieur le déo vous
connaissez très bien tout ce domaine là
c'est la génétique et les variétés et
donc faire des variétés tolérantes aux
maladies c'est quelque chose que l'on
fait depuis très longtemps
qui a été tout compte fait assez peu
utilisé quand vous regardez les outils
d'aide à la décision pour piloter le la
protection des cultures et ben il a
fallu attendre pratiquement la fin des
années 2010 pour les voir apparaître
pouvoir apparaître le niveau de
résistance variétale dans les outils
d'aide à la décision et pourtant ce sont
des choses qui marchent très bien
on a un exemple que l'on connaît que
j'ai eu l'occasion d'évoquer à des
auditions avec l'OPEX qui est l'exemple
des vignes résistantes qu'on a fait des
cépages où on a plusieurs gènes de
résistance aux mildou et on avait parlé
de ça quand nous étions à gruissants
plusieurs gènes de résistance au milieu
plusieurs gènes de résistance à l'audium
et on arrive sur un déploiement en
conditions agricoles à faire en moyenne
moins 87% de fongicides utilisés sa
culture là et comme sur la vigne il y a
quasiment que ça une vraie réduction et
où la question qu'on se pose aujourd'hui
c'est en fait on gère à terme le
déploiement de ça pour éviter les
contournements là aussi le la diversité
biologique n'a qu'une seule envie c'est
de vivre et au milieu de ces levier là
et c'est dans ce contexte de levier là
que sincère les les NBT ou les NT
comment on veut donc les nouvelles
techniques d'édition du génome c'est une
technologie et comme on a eu l'occasion
souvent d'en parler la technologie ne
dit rien de l'endroit où on veut aller
et voilà la vraie question que l'on a
sur les l'édition du génome c'est à quoi
on l'utilise et comment on l'utilise
donc ça c'était le deuxième levier le
troisième levier c'est tout ce qui va
concerner les agro-équipements et je
vais les étendre en les tendant à la
question du digital c'est quelque chose
qui compte fait aujourd'hui est assez
peu mobilisée hormis l'évolution sur les
techniques de pulvérisation de précision
mais on voit apparaître des potentiels
absolument considérables sur le
désherbage mécanique alors tout le monde
connaît le principe des bineuses mais il
y a des offres aujourd'hui par des
constructeurs et notamment le plus
avancé dans ce secteur là est un
constructeur allemand qui s'appelle
Lemken qui a fait une bineuse qui
viennent à la fois entre les rangs et
sur le rang avec une efficacité
totalement absolument redoutable tout ça
est piloté par des capteurs qui
reconnaissent les plantes et par un
outil d'aide à la décision fin de pardon
de une intelligence artificielle qui est
capable de piloter tous les droits les
droits qui courent en dessous de cette
machine là et elle le fait en fait avec
une vitesse de déplacement qui est très
élevée puisque la machine peut se
déplacer jusqu'à 8 km/h sans jamais
couper la moindre plante que vous
cherchez à protéger il y a des robots le
plus robot le plus intéressant c'est le
robot qui s'appelle farm droïne ou en
fait on a à la fois c'est le même robot
qui s'aiment et qui désherbe donc il
sait en fait où il a semé les les
plantes et donc il va désherber autour
il y a des avancées sur les drones qui
sont utilisés aujourd'hui pour pour
déposer certains produits de biocontrôle
et puis il y a des choses auxquelles
auxquelles on pense pas mais qui sont
d'une efficacité redoutable et très peu
cher on utilise par exemple des produits
pour faire de l'éclaircissage sur les
pommiers sur les pruniers sur les
la partie prunus malus et Pyrrhus tout
cela
et en fait on utilise un produit qui est
un en fait un désherbant de betterave
qui a été détourné de son usage initial
donc et la métamytrone difficile à
appliquer qui coûte très cher et il y a
un constructeur qui a inventé une
machine qui est simplement un rotor qui
est pas motoris enfin espèce de grand
bras avec des longues fibres de verre et
en passant dans les couverts en fait par
simple vibration il fait tomber les
jeunes fruits au moment où on en a on a
besoin de les enlever et on peut le
faire avec l'intensité que l'on veut
donc on peut maux de fin
gérer complètement contrôlé complètement
la charge en fruits et là aussi c'est
très peu cher mais bizarrement très
difficile à adopter puis le dernier
levier c'est celui que vous avez
mentionné sur le déo qui est levé du
biocontrôle en fait le biocontrôle
marque pour l'essentiel une rupture
totale dans la façon de penser la santé
des plantes en fait par rapport et vous
posez la question de est-ce que c'est
qu'on fait des pesticides moins
dangereux en fait un pastille il a pour
l'objectif de tuer le biocontrôle a pour
l'objectif de contrôler et ça veut dire
que vous cherchez à réguler une
population pour la maintenir en dessous
du niveau de seuil mais sans jamais
l'amener à zéro et donc les différents
leviers que vous avez dans le les
différents blocs dans le dans le
biocontrôle il y a quelques substances
naturelles comme le soufre et le cuivre
mais l'essentiel et les grands champs de
développement c'est autour des trois
autres grands leviers pour lequel il y a
des avancées de science qui sont
majeures c'est les micro-organismes et
je rajouterai à ça à cette question des
parents des parents les macros
organismes
pour les coccinelles et les chrysopes
mais à laquelle je rajouterai la
question la technologie des insectes
stériles c'est-à-dire on régule une
population en mettant des mâles que l'on
a stérilisé comme les la plupart pour la
plupart des des insectes il y a qu'un
seul accouplement et ben en fait si vous
mettez des insectes stériles il y a des
mâles stériles il y a peu de descendance
donc il y a pas la population albès mais
elle n'est jamais mise à zéro en fait
parce qu'il y a toujours quelques mâles
qui traînent
le deuxième grand bloc c'est les
micro-organismes et en fait avec des
champs de découverte absolument
considérables qui est la découverte qui
a un microbiote sur le végétal dans le
végétal et un microbiote du sol et tout
ça en fait va moduler à la fois la façon
dont la plante va se protéger la façon
de la plante va se nourrir c'est un
champ d'innovation absolument
considérable et extrêmement prometteur
pouvant aller jusque l'analyse du
microbiote des semences c'est utiliser
la semence comme étant en fait nos
vecteurs d'un microbiote permettant la
protection de la plante après et puis le
troisième grand bloc c'est les
phéromones alors les phéromones et les
queromones c'est la découverte du fait
que les insectes se déplacent en
fonction d'un champ d'odeur et il se
déplace que pour deux raisons la
première c'est se reproduire et la
deuxième c'est manger et ils sont
sensibles à très très peu de composer
organique donc il y a des composés
organiques volatiles sont soit les
composés organiques relatifs de
reproduction et donc c'est des
phéromones et si vous saturez un espace
avec des phéromones
le mal ne trouve jamais la femelle
mais il prend son pied en permanence et
c'est une boutade et mais c'est utilisé
en fait à des échelles relativement
grandes dans des vergers ou dans des
vignobles et ça suppose en fait des
organisations collectives parce que si
vous êtes vous pouvez pas faire ça dans
votre jardin si vous avez un arbre en
fait il faut que ça soit sur des
paysages relativement grands et puis le
deuxième élément c'est il se déplace
pour aller se nourrir donc en fait il
repère sa proie sa cible et c'est vrai
pour un macro-organisme comme pour un
puceron qui a envie d'aller manger une
betterave et donc on peut changer en
fait ces paysages olfactif en apportant
très très peu de molécules et donc à ce
moment là on modifie et la traction et
son niveau de d'alimentation bref on
dispose aujourd'hui d'un ensemble de
leviers techniques qui sont à combiner
et avec en plus avec des innovations
fortes extrêmement importantes et je dis
il sera combiné entre eux et ils sont à
combiner avec les molécules chimiques
qu'on utilise en dernier ressort et pas
en premier ressort et ce qui fait qu'en
fait la capacité à bouger elle va varier
selon l'espèce et la culture et la
culture sur lesquelles le champ est plus
élevé vous pouvez difficilement faire
des rotations dans des vignes quoi voilà
donc il y a des il y a des possibilités
qui existent qui sont pas les mêmes
partout et donc il va falloir réfléchir
à tout ça alors la vraie question c'est
pourquoi de compte fait sa bouche pas
plus vite que ce que l'on a vu sur les
dernières années ont d'abord ça bouge
pas plus vite parce qu'en fait il y a un
problématique d'offres qui doit se qui
doit s'aligner mais il y a aussi des
phénomènes ce qu'on appelle en sciences
de gestion les verrouillages sociaux
techniques à savoir l'ensemble du
système est organisé parce que les
phytos c'est facile à utiliser et tu
comptes fait c'est très peu cher par
rapport à l'ensemble du système de
production donc il faut déverrouiller ce
système là et un des acteurs essentiels
au déverrouillage c'est l'aval et sur le
déo vous posiez la question de qu'est-ce
qui du ressort du seul mode de la
production et comment on associe les
autres mais il peut pas y avoir de
mouvement s'il y a pas Laval qu'à un
moment donné prend ses responsabilités
là dedans
et l'aval en fait il doit et ça rejoint
le titre de la controverse il doit aussi
anticiper l'évolution de la demande
alimentaire la demande alimentaire elle
bouge elle change et donc comment on
arrive à l'anticiper en travaillant avec
le l'ensemble de la production jusqu'à
la transformation il y a une question
pour le pour le mouvement qui est la
gestion du risque et donc comment on
couvre le risque non pas d'une maladie
mais comment on couvre le risque de la
transition parce que le déplacement d'un
système très connu vers un autre système
engendre un risque et puis un rôle
central sur le conseil et la formation
il y a un point que je n'ai pas
mentionné qui est quelque chose qu'il
faut obligatoirement réfléchir pour
demain c'est anticiper les effets du
changement climatique dans ce contexte
là ça va avoir une un impact sur les
cultures est-ce que l'on pourrait faire
est-ce que l'on pourra faire et en même
temps savoir avoir un impact sur les
risques liés agresseur et en particulier
les biogresseurs émergents et pour finir
je pense avoir été un petit peu trop
long pour la recherche en fait il y a
une forme de responsabilité autour de ça
et je bouclerai avec le programme
prioritaire de recherche que vous avez
mentionnées il est de la responsabilité
de la recherche d'attaquer des fronts de
sciences si on fait la même chose que ce
qu'on faisait depuis toujours il faut
qu'on arrête d'être chercheur et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis un objectif un
programme de recherche autour de d'une
idée zéro pesticides c'est pas un
scénario prescriptif c'est de dire si on
met ce scénario là quels sont les fronts
de sciences qu'on est amené à explorer
et c'est ce qui permet d'aller
aujourd'hui de faire des avancées
considérables sur les micro-organismes
sur les phéromones et sur les questions
d'épidémie surveillance voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire le seul président
beaucoup donc tout de suite madame
chancigo vous vous traitez de la
question des rapports entre les
pesticides et l'environnement et l'homme
bonjour bonjour monsieur le Président
je vais apporter un éclairage un petit
peu un petit peu différent parce que
j'ai abordé la question des pesticides
d'un point de vue historique
de et c'est utile en fait de revenir sur
sur le passé non pas parce que c'est une
question d'érudition mais parce que très
souvent ça éclaire sur des
problématiques actuelles et qu'on ne
peut pas avancer sans avoir la mémoire
de ce qui nous a précédé
les pesticides modernes naissent à la
fin du 19e dans un univers assez
particulier qui sont les États-Unis
d'Amérique
et qui possède une agriculture très
différente de l'ancienne Europe avec des
monocultures beaucoup plus vastes avec
des espèces cultivées qui ne sont pas
originaires de ce continent et qui se
trouve dans un système on va dire
écologique complètement nouveau
imaginez des plantations à perte de vue
d'une seule espèce c'est un peu le le
paradis pour une espèce d'insecte qui
peut se mettre très facilement en
proliférer et comme les espèces
d'insectes ravageurs ravageuses sont
également introduites elles se trouvent
confronté à la même chose c'est à dire
aucun
aucun concurrent aucun parasite ou
parasitoïde ne pourrait les limiter
cet agriculture est donc frontalement
touché par des questions
d'entomophones
vraiment dramatique et le monde agricole
américain réclame une solution technique
scientifique
le gouvernement de Washington dans le
dans les années
70-1870 commissionnent des scientifiques
qui fait des préconisations assez
simples dans les plantations de coton
qui fait face à l'attaque du charançon
du cotonnier c'est de faire de la
polyculture lorsqu'une parcelle est
atteinte par le charrançon il faut
brûler la récolte ainsi que les champs à
foisinents et ça c'est quelque chose qui
heurte complètement le monde agricole
qui refuse
d'envisager ce type de solutions on a
des témoignages extrêmement clairs qui
réclament de faire la même agriculture
que son père et son grand-père
les
les agriculteurs expérimentent
énormément de choses ils sont très
imaginatifs par exemple de faire courir
sur le sol des câbles électriques pour
électrocuter les larves qui vivent dans
le sol bien évidemment ça n'a aucune
efficacité et il se tourne vers divers
procédés chimiques que ça soit du
pétrole ou que ça soit et surtout de
l'arsenic l'arsenic va devenir la
molécule phare de cette agriculture
comme d'ailleurs c'est la molécule
phare de de l'Occident on la retrouve
absolument de partout notamment et je
cite souvent ça parce que ça montre cet
usage dans les bonbons pour enfants
parce que ça donne une jolie couleur
verte
ces arsenics sont produits en Allemagne
il y a pas d'industrie réellement
chimiques aux États-Unis et quand on
regarde la
littérature agricole on est fasciné de
voir à partir de ces années 1870 la
multiplication de tout ce qui est
appareillage pour pulvériser y compris
sur des surfaces très grandes ou des
végétaux très hauts de l'arsenic
c'est
cette question va changer radicalement
avec l'arrivée de la première guerre
mondiale et le blocus qui limite les
importations de produits chimiques
venant d'Allemagne et va se développer
sur le sol américain les grandes
compagnies chimiques que l'on connaît
aujourd'hui
la fin de la guerre entraîne un
recyclage cette industrie chimique vers
la production
davantage de pesticides d'autant que il
y a une arme de guerre qui va être
également recyclée à savoir les avions
et les pilotes qui reviennent du front
et on assiste aux premiers épandages
aériens
cette question est intéressante parce
que pour la première fois durant
l'entrée de guerre on voit apparaître
aux États-Unis toujours les premiers
mouvements de conservateur de
consommateurs et en 1933 paraît un livre
absolument passionnant de deux militants
de la cause des consommateurs qui
attirent l'attention sur les dangers
qu'il y a à s'alimenter mais également
les dangers que l'on a à se soigner ou à
prendre
utiliser des produits de beauté en
raison des risques sous-jacents
ils estiment que le
dans une analyse qui est assez
foudroyante à lire par rapport aux
problématiques actuelles que le grand
problème est un problème en fait de
fonctionnement de la démocratie parce
que les grandes compagnies en fait
empêchent la circulation des
informations
libres et objectifs et bien sûr humilite
pour la fabrication de cette
connaissance
l'arrivée de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
va marquer une étape décisive dans
l'accélération de l'utilisation des
pesticides
notamment parce que l'armée américaine
fait face à deux problèmes liés aux
insectes le paludisme sur le front du
Pacifique parce que les troupes
japonaises ont occupées l'Indonésie il
n'y a plus d'obtention de quinine
nécessaire
pour soigner le paludisme et sur le
front européen il y a la menace du
typhus
qui peut ravager comme le paludisme
d'ailleurs une armée beaucoup plus
efficacement que les armes et demi
les États-Unis vont découvrir le DDT qui
est mise au point du moins la toxicité à
l'égard des insectes et découvertes par
un chimiste suisse qui de façon très
neutre propose sa molécule tant aux
forces de l'Axe aux alliés
les Allemands en fait ne sont pas
intéressés par le DDT parce qu'ils ont
assez de stock de produits
végétaux et par contre pour les
Américains l'intérêt est très grand et
le premier usage va se faire à Naples où
il y a un début d'épidémie typhus
et on observe en fait la première
pulvérisation comme arme j'irai de
guerre même si ça ne change absolument
pas la direction du conflit
ça c'est en 43 en 46 on observe le
premier cas de résistance chez des
insectes justement à Naples les choses
sont extrêmement vides dans le monde des
petites bêtes
et en 45 il y a un engouement absolument
fabuleux à l'égard du DDT qui est
considéré comme la bombe atomique de
l'insecte qui est capable en fait de
résoudre définitivement tous les
problèmes posés par par les insectes
quel qu'il soit et immédiatement
également mais toute une activité de
d'examen attentifs et critiques de cela
de la part d'associations de naturalisme
qui ont des tailles largement
supérieures qu'on peut connaître en
France avec les sociétés ou du bon de
protection des oiseaux qui organise des
45 des tables rondes de réflexion sur
ces sur ces usages
et on va voir une production de
littérature scientifique assez sur ce
sujet absolument important des 45 avec
d'ailleurs des des spécialistes qui
lancent des avertissements en disant que
si on a une substance capable de tuer
tous les insectes en fait l'humanité va
suivre parce que l'humanité ne peut pas
survivre sans insecte
7 littérature qui continue à s'accumuler
ne circule guère en dehors des cercles
soit de naturalisme soit de
scientifiques spécialisés de ces
questions et c'est Rachel Carson en 63
avec son livre printemps silencieux qui
va faire la synthèse de ses
connaissances scientifiques et elle va
faire quelque chose qui va être une
révolution dans le domaine de
l'environnement c'est que jusqu'à
présent ces questions ne comment dire
n'était abordé que par quelques
scientifiques
des instances politiques les producteurs
chimiques et le monde agricole et elle
fait rentrer un nouvel acteur dans cette
question à savoir le grand public Rachel
Carson est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
célèbre sont les c'est une biologiste
marin qui a fait plusieurs ouvrages de
vulgarisation et le deuxième est resté
en tête des ventes du Nord Times pendant
plus d'un an
et elle met en fait au service de cette
cause cette notoriété et effectivement
ça va très bien marcher parce que son
livre va être vendu à des millions
d'exemplaires et va provoquer en fait la
naissance du mouvement environnemental
contemporains qu'on peut le connaître
et entraîner en 70 l'interdiction du DDT
il est intéressant de noter que Rachel
Carson va être traduite assez vite en
français avec deux modifications
notables d'une part toute sa
bibliographie amputée
ce qui en fait juste une sorte d'essai
c'est plus un ouvrage de synthèse tel
qu'elle l'avait conçu et il est présenté
par ogeaïm directeur du Muséum comme une
journaliste ce qu'elle n'est pas puisque
c'est une scientifique qui travaille qui
a travaillé longtemps pour le bureau des
des pêches
cette question est intéressante parce
que on voit que pendant très longtemps
le développement de cette industrie
chimique et de cet usage de la chimie
s'est faite sans intervention du tout du
ou sans participation du tout du public
il a fallu effectivement une action
particulière pour rendre cette question
visible par le grand public on considère
à schal Carson comme une lanceuse
d'alerte ce qui est faux c'est bel et
bien en fait on travaille
fondamentalement un travail de
vulgarisation scientifique
il est d'ailleurs intéressant qu'il y a
d'autres d'autres sujets qui
effectivement sont très peu abordés par
exemple cette question de la résistance
des insectes qui est connue dès 43 les
premiers exemples de résistance aux
arsenico sont
repérés dès les années 20 en 43 ces
théorisé du point de vue de la biologie
évolutive et en fait on se rend compte
que dès que le DDT arrive on sait les
problèmes que ça va faire surgir en
termes de résistance on a une situation
totalement similaire et étudier les deux
en parallèle et absolument fascinant
avec la question des antibiotiques et de
la résistance aux antibiotiques qui
pronostiquée quasiment tout de suite dès
la découverte de la pénicilline sans que
ça entraîne un changement de pratique il
y aura interrogé d'ailleurs sur
l'influence des connaissances sur la la
prise de décision parce que dans
certains cas et dans certains problèmes
liés à l'environnement on a l'impression
que les connaissances savent pas à grand
chose pour prendre des décisions
intelligentes vous êtes l'exemple
absolument contraire et vraiment je vous
en remercie
les la question de ces de ces insectes
posent aussi un autre aspect qui est
largement
ignoré du grand public qui est la
question de l'introduction des espèces
envahissants
on peut d'ailleurs se féliciter d'avoir
eu la chance d'avoir une épidémie de
covid sans insectes vecteur parce que ça
aurait changé je pense pas mal la donne
en termes de contrôle de l'usage des
pesticides
et on assiste à une situation assez
paradoxale contradictoires entre
l'augmentation du nombre d'espèces
envahissantes qui posent des problèmes
absolument
grandissant et redoutable et la volonté
de diminuer l'arsenal chimique il y a
une sorte de contradiction cognitive
absolument absolument parfaite le fait
que le public soit peu concerné par ces
questions d'espèces envahissantes
explique peut-être cela
juste pour terminer puisqu'on a fait
référence au chlore des cônes
il y a une grande différence
chronologique entre la France et les
États-Unis en termes de contrôle du
chlore d'école et
j'expliquerai cette différence par le
tissu relativement plus faible en France
des associations naturalistes qui n'ont
pas du tout la même taille
aux États-Unis et qui ont une puissance
de frappe absolument considérable en
matière de de d'épaulement de la
recherche scientifique et de diffusion
des connaissances dont on commandait
dont on n'a pas du tout d'équivalent
c'est pas la taille du pays qui explique
ces différences c'est vraiment une
popularisation beaucoup plus forte et ça
ça explique sans doute cette difficulté
qu'il y a eu un reconnaître un problème
qui était reconnu depuis assez longtemps
aux États-Unis il y a pas de rapport
entre le sucre et le vin la
chaptalisation c'est fini
un certain temps un changement
climatique et a contribué dans la
question que vous posez madame la
sénatrice sur le sur la question du 20
et la question en fait de la vitesse à
laquelle il y en ao bouge ou une bouche
pas en fait ça montre que les
cahiers des charges définis par les NAO
sont des constructions humaines là où
les problématiques d'insectes et les
problématiques de climat l'humain a pesé
sur le climat mais c'est chose qui les
contraintes qui viennent de l'extérieur
et donc la vraie question elle est
comment les cahiers des charges peuvent
évoluer d'une part en fonction de
l'objectif qu'il poursuivent et d'autre
part pour intégrer le changement
climatique comme vous l'avez dit ou
intégrer les problématiques de réduction
des phytos d'autre part et donc l'action
c'est les logiques les questions de
temporalité d'une part et les questions
de cohérence entre politique publique ou
cahier des charges privées et donc
effectivement cette question là les
débattue aujourd'hui avec l'INAO et il y
a une petite ouverture qui a été faite
par exemple les cépages résistants qui
soient autorisés à de 5 à 10% ce qu'on
appelle les vifs pour
pour justement permettre la introduction
et puis dans le cadre des cépages
résistants en situation d'appellation
c'est la possibilité de les localiser en
bordure de de parcelles et à proximité
des habitations pour gérer les zones non
traitées
[Musique]
concernant la betterave c'est un sujet
que je connais plutôt assez bien étant
responsable du comité de coordination
technique du plan néonicotinoïde enfin
sorti des néonicotinoïdes la question
elle est intéressante en fait quand vous
la regardez de tas de points de vue en
fait d'abord on inévitablement on est
amené à s'interroger pourquoi on a
commencé à traiter ce plan cette
question des néonicotinées dans
betteraves aussi tard c'est-à-dire on a
dû attendre la catastrophe de 2020 on a
de fait perdu 27% de de la production en
moyenne française alors qu'on sait
depuis 2014 que l'on va sortir des
choses et en fait il a fallu qu'on
attende d'être dans le mur j'ai commencé
à dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça montre en
fait juste que on est extrêmement
verrouillé autour d'un intrant qui était
un intrant incroyablement simple savoir
que il est tellement simple qu'on avait
même pas à l'appliquer vu qu'il était
sur la graine et il nettoyait absolument
tout vu que les néonicotinoïdes en fait
on tape sur une cible qui est partagée
par l'ensemble des insectes et un grand
nombre d'arthropodes et donc
de fait c'était le vide alors c'était le
Silent Spring appliqué aux parcelles de
betterave et en plus avec des produits
qui sont systémiques donc qui circulent
dans la plante et qui ont un temps et le
vrai problème il est celui-là en fait
une des demi-vie incroyablement longue
vu que on a utilisé pendant longtemps de
limited qui a une demi-vie de 228 jours
ça veut dire que beaucoup au bout de 228
jours vous avez encore 50% du produit
qui est dans le milieu et donc si vous
faites deux fois ça vous avez encore 25%
ce qui fait qu'au bout d'un an et demi
vous avez encore dans le plan dans le
sol
suffisamment de produits pour flinguer à
peu près tout ce qui ressemble à un
insecte donc de fait il fallait sortir
de ce truc là alors quand on dit en fait
ça ne marche pas et effectivement les au
bout de deux ans de travaux les
différents leviers sont pas tous au même
niveau de maturité les variétés
résistantes ou plutôt les rentes elles
sont juste encore en cours de création
et les autres leviers ils sont tous des
leviers à effet partielle et c'est là
que je dis c'est le point central c'est
il y a pas d'alternative effectivement
le monde des betteraviers
ce après quoi il court c'est le produit
qui fera exactement la même chose donc
ils rêvait d'avoir un insecte ici qui
appliqué en foliaire ferait la même
chose en nettoyant absolument tout
ce que l'on sait c'est qu'il faut
utiliser nvid différents et donc les n
de vie qu'on utilise c'est effectivement
travailler sur des variétés qui vont
supporter une présence de virus deuxième
point c'est retarder énormément
l'arrivée des pucerons alors les
pucerons on est capable de modéliser
aujourd'hui pratiquement au jour près le
jour ils vont arriver des qu'on arrive
aucun février et qu'on a enregistré les
températures on peut vous dire donner
une carte cette annonce on s'est trompé
de 0 jours voilà quel que soit l'endroit
où on était c'est lié au fait que les
dates à laquelle ils arrivent et liées à
une courbe exponentielle de
développement dans le début est basé sur
les températures
donc on connaît leur date d'arrivée si
l'arrivée très précoce bah il faut peser
pour que quand ils arrivent ils se
développe très peu d'où le fait qu'on
utilise un levier qui est les plantes
campagnes alors ça pour le monde
agricole c'est très compliqué à
comprendre parce que on dit on fait des
betteraves qui sont très sensibles à la
compétition et on ajoute quelque chose
d'autre il faut l'ajouter pour couvrir
le risque s'il est très précoce ensuite
on joue sur des des phéromones
c'est-à-dire des de produits répulsif il
y a des choses qui sont testées cette
année en très grande échelle et les
résultats que j'ai depuis la semaine
dernière montent qu'on arrive à réduire
de façon extrêmement forte la population
de pucerons à très grande échelle ce qui
est plutôt une très bonne nouvelle et on
réduit la population mais on maintient
le même niveau de la population de des
auxiliaires ça veut dire qu'ils prennent
le relais et donc ça c'est plutôt un
très très bon point et puis le troisième
levier qui a enlevé qu'on n'avait pas
identifié au début qui était de dire il
faut qu'on réduise les réservoirs viraux
c'est un puceron est né il est propre
donc s'il a aucun endroit où il peut
aller récupérer un virus bah il peut
venir il fera rien et en fait la
question c'est où sont les réservoirs
environ et on sait aujourd'hui qu'ils
sont à deux endroits pour l'essentiel
enfin deux et demi je vais donner le
demi après le premier c'est que dans le
sud du Bassin parisien il y a 800
hectares de production de semences de
betteraves qui sont semés à l'automne et
récolter au printemps d'après et donc en
fait ils font la jointure entre deux
saisons et ils sont plein de virus tous
les virus sont dedans dans toutes les
parcelles et l'autre c'est toutes les
repousses de betteraves il y a 400000
hectares de betteraves en France
ça a quasiment pas bougé il y en a 50%
pour l'essentiel c'est suivi par une
céréale et 50% de céréales sont semées
en semis direct ça veut dire que tous
les résidus de culture de la culture
d'avance sont encore à la surface du sol
il y a en moyenne sur les 80 tonnes
qu'on récolte il y a une tonne qui n'est
pas récolté chez des petites betteraves
elles restent à la surface du sol on a
rien perdu sauf qu'elles vont repousser
au printemps d'après et elles vont faire
des feuilles et ça va devenir des
sources pour les virus et en fait faut
changer les programmes de désherbage sur
les céréales
alors vous allez dire j'ai dit qu'il
fallait mettre moins de désherbant bah
oui il faut apprendre à les gérer aussi
pour que en fait on passe un antidicote
avant l'antigraminées et puis il y a ce
qui s'appelle les cordons de des
terrasses c'est-à-dire quand les silos
sont récoltés et ils sont récoltés tard
et ben en fait la terre reste là et elle
il y a des tas de repousses en fait
c'est des montagnes de feuilles de
betterave et quand vous regardez c'est
tout plein de virus et donc il faut les
apprendre à les gérer et l'élément
intéressant je le disais c'est la prise
de prévu juste avant c'est qu'en fait
cette année on a attiré cette sonnette
d'alarme auprès des professionnels et en
fait cette année il y a une action
extrêmement forte de tous les
agriculteurs pour qu'il y ait pas se
repoussent là
il y a pas il y a pas de solution
miracle des miracles il y en a plus
depuis longtemps et sur ce truc là ça va
être la combinaison de N levier qui va
permettre d'y arriver et moi je suis pas
inquiet objectivement ça va supposer que
la représentation que l'on fait se fasse
de cet objet-là change beaucoup au cours
du temps mais on va y arriver
oui c'est vraiment le point je pense le
plus important c'est que toutes ces
questions qui semblent relever de la
biologie que ça soit de l'écologie de la
biochimie de la génétique etc soit
associer sans doute je vais faire la
promotion pour m'échapper aux sciences
humaines et sociales pour qu'on
comprenne les mécanismes qui peut
freiner en fait l'adoption de de
nouvelles techniques le fait de quels
sont les freins au changement pourquoi
le changement fait peur pourquoi il peut
y avoir des attentes contradictoires par
exemple dans le grand public c'est clair
qu'il y a à la fois une sorte de
détestation rampante des pesticides et
en même temps de détestation tout à fait
flagrante des insectes on imagine pas
[Musique]
comment dire vivre en paix et en
harmonie et ça ça relève effectivement
d'une approche qui mériterait vraiment
d'être conduite toujours en parallèle
pour pas oublier une partie de la
question
voilà pour ces tables ronds d'organiser
à l'occasion des 40 ans de l'OPEX
l'Office parlementaire d'évaluation des
choix scientifiques et technologiques je
le rappelle c'est un organe commun aux
deux chambres du Parlement qui a pour
mission d'informer les parlementaires
sur les conséquences de nos choix
scientifiques et technologiques voilà
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi continuez à suivre
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
sur notre site internet public sénat.fr
je vous souhaite une très bonne journée
sur Public Sénat
[Musique]